we asked our audience uh three true or
false financial questions and you're
going to help us unlock the correct
answer first true or false when cutting
back on spending should you start with
streaming service subscriptions and apps
that incur monthly fees
okay so our poll revealed that 61 of the
audience said this is true
sounds kind of rational
what is the answer so this one i'm gonna
say false on and i'll give you a reason
why is because it is easy to cut on
netflix you know it's the easy low
hanging fruit but
um it's it's gonna save you maybe 15 per
month and that's not really gonna you
know move the needle as much as you
might think when saving or
trying to save so what i encourage
people to do is start with their the big
three your three biggest expenses that's
housing transportation and food so if
you start with the big three that's how
you actually save much more in the long
term so for example um you know if
you're living in a studio apartment
maybe you could like you're renting an
apartment if you get a roommate you can
actually save
you know five six hundred dollars per
month um just by getting a roommate or
what's also becoming popular if you own
a home you can rent out a room uh to a
friend or family member and they can
help pay for your mortgage so doing that
you're actually saving hundreds of
dollars per month that's going to move
the needle much more than just cutting
on 15 netflix that is the kind of wisdom
you're like oh 15 a month won't move the
needle hundreds of dollars a month
exactly needle mover i love this okay so
tangible next true or false you should
charge smaller expenses and
your services to your credit card
instead of debit card i loved this
question our poll revealed 44 of the
audience said that was true john what is
the real answer
i would say true on this okay yes yes so
that's good um the reason you want to
put smaller expenses on your credit card
is because if you're maxing out your
credit card every single month that's
actually going to hurt your credit score
and so we want to put the small
expenses on it like maybe gas
groceries things you can pay off in full
every single month so i always recommend
putting small expenses recurring
expenses on your credit card you can pay
it off in full every month you'll build
a good credit score and you'll never go
into credit card debt i love that thank
you that is small expensive so helpful
okay
last one true or false the best way to
divide your monthly income is equally 33
for your needs then wants then savings
our audience said 46
said yeah that sounds like a good
approach john what is a good approach
so in an ideal world 33 for your needs
33 for your wants 33 for your savings
but that's maybe not realistic in the
personal finance community um we like to
go with the 50 30 20 rule so 50
for your needs
um that's housing maybe child care
things like that 30
for your uh once that's vacations maybe
going out things like that and then 20
for saving and investing so that is much
more realistic and i promise if you're
saving and investing 20 of your income
you will become wealthy over time so
and just like as a side note like what
do you think are good
things to look out for investment wise
for people yeah i think investment wise
um and it definitely depends on your
situation each time but real estate is
always going to stand the test of time
right you know buying and owning your
own home is going to be a good idea and
then
when it's investing in maybe stocks i
always recommend an index fund which an
index fund is like a gift basket full of
stocks so it's like you can own tesla
google facebook microsoft like a bunch
of different stocks together in one
nicely packaged gift basket so and we
know those companies are not going
anywhere anytime soon that's right
exactly exactly it's safe and you can
grow your money that way i love that
thank you i so appreciate that john
ehringman thank you so much for coming
on
[Applause]
financial tips and tricks
[Music]